im nordatlantik zerbricht ein riesiger
frachter in zwei teile
es ging wahnsinnig schnell buchstäblich
in schallgeschwindigkeit
25 männer kämpfen verzweifelt ums
überleben es war furchtbar
das schiff war nicht mehr zu retten
hast du medaille punkt warum haben wir
so viele männer verloren warum ist das
schiff überhaupt auseinander gebrochen
die suche nach antworten für die
ermittler auf den meeresgrund und siehe
da sein und zu weiteren mysteriösen
schiffs untergingen das sind alles
frachter niemand weiß was mit diesen
schiffen passiert ist wahnsinn sie sind
einfach verschwunden
winter im nordatlantik der 180 meter
lange massengutfrachter flair fährt
richtung besten
massengutfrachter leisten schwerstarbeit
sie sind für den transport schwerer
güter konzipiert und sind in der ganzen
welt unterwegs
der höheren geschwindigkeit auf zwölf
knoten der kapitän und die 24
crewmitglieder sind gerade durch einen
heftigen wintersturm gefahren und der
nächste lauert bereits am horizont
ross halten alte kurs am ruder ist der
23-jährige cyrus wird erst neu an bord
und hat erst kurz vor dem auslaufen
angeheuert
ich war voll matrose auf der flair und
für die manuelle steuerung zuständig
ich wollte schon immer zur see fahren
mein onkel war auch seemann
er als ich noch klein war kam er immer
glücklich nach hause und hatte die
taschen voller geld deswegen wollte ich
auch zur see fahren
die flair hat gut die hälfte ihrer 6000
kilometer langen reise von rotterdam
nach montreal zurückgelegt dort soll sie
getreide laden
der chef ist mit riesigen kränen
ausgestattet sie können fast 38.000
kubikmeter fracht in ihre sieben
laderäume hilfen
doch heute sind die laderäume leer
unter deck führte vierte ingenieure
maradona paar reparaturarbeiten an einem
der ballasttanks durch
[Musik]
wir waren im obersten tank
die schweißarbeiten dauerten fast den
ganzen tag
auch japans neuem team als einige wochen
zuvor mit fern an bord kam wurden beide
von petronas empfangen einem erfahrenen
simon
er war von anfang an sehr hilfsbereit
ich war noch grün hinter den ohren und
er hatte mir alles erklärt so war er
die flair nähert sich der cap straße vor
kanada eine gegend die für ihr aus klima
bekannt ist
jfr
langsamer 5 knoten
kapitän cris hirn stammt aus neufundland
mit unruhiger see kennt er sich aus
die caps straße liegt zwischen zwei
landmassen mit unterschiedlichen
wetterbedingungen
hier fließen schnellere und langsamere
strömungen zusammen und diese energie
peitscht die wellen in die höhe
die crew sichert die rettungsboote damit
sie während des sturms nicht verloren
gehen
die wellen schlugen hoch und der wind
war extrem laut man konnte das pärchen
hören
lukas
steuerbord erhalten
da das schiff keine ladung an bord hatte
war es den elementen viel stärker
ausgesetzt es musste einiges einstecken
man konnte spüren wie die vibrationen
durch den rumpf zogen
ich sah wie das schiff in den hohen
wellen geborgen wurde
ein verstörender anblick aber ein schiff
wie die flair ist für solche bedingungen
konzipiert
alle schiffe sind elastisch konstruiert
vor allem sehr lange schiffe sie biegen
und bewegen sich die ganze zeit
die wellen türmen sich neun meter hoch
auf so hoch wie ein dreistöckiges
gebäude
es war wahnsinnig laut als die wellen
gegen die brücke schlugen
gute nacht gute nacht
um zwei uhr morgens endet verwehren
schicht er will sich zur ruhe legen doch
der sturm beraubt ihm den schlaf
man konnte bei dem wetter mit diesem
wellengang einfach nicht schlafen
ich sah zwar nicht spürte aber das
schaukeln und schlagen
wir werden zu schnell
war im maschinenraum versuchen ab und
sein assistent ein überhitzen der
maschinen zu verhindern
wir mussten ständig die geschwindigkeit
anpassen
immer wenn das schiff durch die wellen
fährt rad das heck ein stück aus dem
wasser
wenn sich das schiff auf und ab bewegt
kann es passieren dass der propeller
frei in der luft hängt
dann fehlt der widerstand und der motor
dreht zu schnell und kann beschädigt
werden
wir durften die maschinen nicht eine
sekunde aus den augen lassen
und zwar während der kompletten schicht
um halb fünf uhr morgens kommt es dann
zur katastrophe
ballack es
gab einen lauten knall was war passiert
waren wir irgendwo gegen gefahren
dann ging der alarm los
allein
runter von dem schiff wir sinken
warte warte
jemand schlug gegen meine tür und sagte
ich solle meine rettungsweste anlegen
habe ich zog zwei hosen und drei paar
socken an
ich bin die treppe fast nicht
hochgekommen weil das schiff solche
schräglage hatte
draußen ist es bitterkalt die männer
sind in panik die meisten sind nur dünn
angezogen
renault hatte noch seinen schlafanzug an
keine socken nur den pyjama und ein t
shirt
doch die kälte ist nichts gegen den
schock der dann folgt die komplette
vordere hälfte des schiffs ist weg
das schiff war in der mitte
durchgebrochen
das war kaum zu glauben
die anderen waren total geschockt
einige weinten
andere
es war furchtbar
wir wussten dass das schiff sinkt
wir mussten irgendwie am leben bleiben
25 männer kämpfen auf einem sinkenden
geborstenen frachter ums überleben in
den eisigen gewässern des nordatlantiks
werden sie nicht lange durchhalten
es war das reinste chaos alle waren in
panik
der kapitän war nirgends zu sehen
wahrscheinlich war er schon über bord
gegangen wir waren also auf uns allein
gestellt
wir versuchten das rettungsboot
runterzulassen doch das gelang uns nicht
das rettungsboot wurde zusätzlich
gesichert damit es während des sturms
nicht verloren geht und jetzt ließen
sich die zur gurte nicht mehr lösen es
war ein kampf auf leben und tod
wir wussten nicht was wir tun sollten
die männer machen sich auf die suche
nach dem bordfunk
hast du midi gefunkt ihr fragten ihn ob
er medias gefunkt hatte nein warum nicht
nicht dazu gekommen was sie können es
nicht fassen dass keine gefunkt wurde
der sos gefunkt hätten wir zumindest
eine chance gerettet zu werden
verzweifelte funker zurück zur brücke um
den notruf doch noch abzusetzen
[Musik]
rang und hatte schlagseite der funk
offiziere mussten über leitern und
treppen zur brücke hochklettern
dass er das überhaupt geschafft hat
grenzt an ein wunder
das mcs die leitstelle in steven will
empfing einen sehr schwachen
unvollständigen notruf über
ultrakurzwelle
sofort beginnen die kanadischen behörden
mit einem groß angelegten
rettungseinsatz doch die koordinaten
sind unvollständig untersucht gebiet
riesig
schiffe flugzeuge und helikopter suchten
ein gebiet ab das 6000 nautische
quadratmeilen umfasst man hoffte das
schiff zu entdecken und damit vielleicht
auch einige überlebende
derweil klammern sich die männer
verzweifelt an die reling des sinkenden
schiffs
tieto ich und die anderen waren alle auf
einer seite des schiffs
wir klammerten uns an die reling und
hatten eine wahnsinns angst
dann sah ich wie tito losließ
wenig später bleibt auch dem rest der
crew keine andere wahl die männer
springen ins wasser während das heck im
atlantik verschwindet
der körperliche schock durch das kalte
wasser ist unglaublich das raubt einem
den atem
ferrari sieht ein umgedrehtes
rettungsboot seine letzte hoffnung
das wasser war eiskalt es tat weh darin
zu schwimmen
es war unglaublich kite
ich hatte eine wahnsinns angst weil wir
von bord mussten und jetzt im wasser
waren
vom rettungsboot hing ein seil herunter
das schnappte ich mir die anderen jungs
kauerten sich im kalten wasser zusammen
zwei andere schaffen es bis zum
rettungsboot
doch wie lange können sie im eisigen
wasser überleben
die unterkühlung setzt ein nach kurzer
zeit kann man seine finger arme und
beine nicht mehr bewegen
auch zwei weitere crewmitglieder
schaffen es bis zum rettungsboot der
funk offizier und tapas assistent doch
so sehr sie sich mühen sie schaffen es
nicht sich anbot festzuhalten
ich hatte einfach nicht genug kraft um
ihn hoch zu ziehen
ich sagte ihm wie leid es mir tat dass
ich ihm nicht helfen konnte
die ende scheint besiegelt dann sehen
sie den bug eines schiffs auf sich
zukommen
jung ist ein amiga samana einer von uns
schrie wir sind gerettet
wir umarmten einander und dachten wir
hätten es geschafft
die rettung es da ich konnte es kaum
glauben
doch als das schiff mehr kommt sehen sie
dass es nur der abgebrochene bug der
flair ist der auf dem wasser treibt
die flair war auseinandergebrochen aber
die wasserdichten schotten waren noch
intakt
die hohlräume hielten den bug über
wasser
das muss ein unheimlicher moment gewesen
sein
wir waren voller hoffnung gewesen aber
als wir das vorderteil des schiffs
erkannten nächsten wir alle hoffnung
fahren
[Musik]
delta viktor bislang kein kontakt ich
wiederhole kein kontakt
bei sonnenuntergang haben die retter
immer noch keine spur des wracks oder
etwaige überlebende
toni 16 und paul chapman vom
rettungsteam schwant nichts gutes
wir wissen ja wie kalt der nordatlantik
ist da waren leute die uns brauchen egal
ob im rettungsboot oder im wasser sie
würden bitterlich frieren
inzwischen war es hell geworden und wir
hatten immer noch niemanden entdeckt
eigentlich ist es nicht schwer jemanden
auf dem wasser zu erkennen aber wir
haben nichts und niemand entdeckt
nach über fünf stunden im eiskalten
wasser schwinden den männern die kräfte
ich betete zu gott
sagte
bitte macht dass ich meine familie
wiedersehen
dann erkennt das rettungsteam etwas am
horizont
da fiel auf 2 uhr
erstaunlicherweise treibt der bug der
flair noch immer im wasser das wrack ist
gefunden aber gibt es noch überlebende
knapp sechs stunden nach dem
unvollständigen notruf sind die retter
endlich fündig geworden
wir haben den buch schon von weitem
schließlich ist er ziemlich groß
die wellen schlugen gegen das war ein
unheimlicher anblick auf der rechten
seite sahen wir einen ölteppich
sie können keine personen auf dem schiff
entdecken doch die erfahrung lehrt gibt
es überlebende so sind sie nicht weit
es gab eine gut erkennbare trümmer linie
über die flogen wir sehr langsam hinweg
wenig später entdeckten wir das
umgedrehte rettungsboot vier männer
hielten sich daran fest einer von ihnen
hoch schwach die hand
bislang gehörten den hubschrauber nahm
und sagten uns wir schaffen das wir
schaffen das
[Musik]
als ich zum rettungsboot kam klammerten
sich alle ganz fest an ihre leinen und
wollten sie kaum loslassen
toni war bauch an bauch mit ihnen als
wir sie hochzogen und reinhold
einer nach dem anderen wird nach oben
gebracht
ich packte sie und holte sie raus
beim letzten staunte ich nicht schlecht
denn er hatte bloß boxershorts an
ich dachte er würde zumindest eine hose
tragen aber das zeigte mir wie c dieser
typ war
mit fast nichts am leibe überstand er am
16 januar sechs stunden im nordatlantik
apa herren und die beiden anderen können
kaum fassen dass sie noch am leben sind
auf der nahe gelegenen insel zum pierre
werden sie medizinisch betreut
[Musik]
das nächste woran ich mich erinnere ist
dass sie uns aus dem helikopter in den
krankenwagen brachten
einer der retter gab mir das abzeichen
von seiner uniform ich war ihm sehr
dankbar
mir war ein zweites leben geschenkt
worden
während die crew medizinisch versorgt
wird suchen die retter den ganzen tag
nach weiteren überlebenden
vergebens
21 männer sind tot
für die familie von petronas es ist es
ein um sagt barczok
es ist so hart aber wir müssen stark
sein er hat so viele opfer für unsere
kinder gebracht
[Musik]
ich fragte damals meine mutter warum
weinst du
und sie sagte mir dass papa gestorben
ist ich wusste nur dass es ein unfall
war aber nicht wie es passiert war
während der bub der flair noch immer auf
dem meer treibt leiten die ermittler der
kanadischen verkehrssicherheitsbehörde
eine untersuchung ein sie wollen wissen
wie das schiff auseinanderbrechen konnte
und warum so viele männer sterben
mussten
ok schauen wir uns die luftaufnahmen an
als erstes denkt man natürlich an die
crew man fragt sich was da los war
das war schon sehr seltsam als wir
hörten was mit dem schiff passiert ist
fast surreal dass eine hälfte des
schiffs noch immer auf dem meer trieb
warum mussten so viele menschen starben
warum haben nicht mehr überlebt wie
konnte das schiff überhaupt auseinander
brechen
ermittler leonard ii ist nach
neufundland gekommen um sich mit dem
leitenden ermittler kapitän will der
coni zu treffen
mal sehen was sie typen uns erzählen
sie hoffen dass die befragung aufschluss
über die unglücksursache geben kann
erzählen sie uns was an diesem tag
passiert ist
man musste überleben dann so schnell wie
möglich befragen denn erinnerungen
können ziemlich schnell verblassen
wir hatten sehr hohem wellengang die
ganze zeit über
das stellt sich heraus dass das schiff
zwei wochen lang ununterbrochen heftigem
sturm ausgesetzt war
wir konnten nichts essen wir konnten
nicht schlafen
die wellen waren sehr hoch
die zeugenaussagen decken sich mit den
wetteraufzeichnungen die in dieser zeit
bis zu 16 meter hohe wellen
verzeichneten
das schiff burg sich etwa so
man sammelt so viele informationen wie
möglich und versucht sich ein klares
bild aller fakten und details zu
verschaffen was haben sie gesehen oder
gehört gab es irgendwelche geräusche als
es geschah
es gab einen lauten knall
in der unglücksnacht würden sie einen
lauten knall
das war der moment des
auseinanderbrechens
alle überlebenden berichten von einem
ohrenbetäubenden geräusch aber keiner
weiß wie es dazu kam
wie kann ein so großes schiff in zwei
teile zerbrechen das müssen wir
herausfinden
[Musik]
die ermittler stehen vor einem rätsel
doch immerhin haben sie bilder des
abgebrochenen bugs aufgenommen in den
vier tagen bevor auch er im meer versank
unglaublich das müssen wir uns näher
ansehen
john gas ding ist maschinenbauingenieur
und experte für schadensanalyse er hofft
dass die bilder hinweise auf die
unglücksursache geben können
das bildmaterial enthält eine enorme
menge an informationen die
fotografien und videos sind aus
ermittlungstechnischen sicht sehr
wertvoll
ein ganz sauberer bruch
hatte die bruchkante untersucht macht
gast in eine überraschende entdeckung
es sieht aus als hätte jemand einen
sauberen schnitt mit einem skalpell
gemacht und dann vieles auseinander
die experten sprechen von einem sprit
bruch
und brüche ereignen sich zb bei glas
wenn glas zerbricht dann passiert das
schlagartig ohne
dass es sich verbiegt die
theorie passt zu den zeugenaussagen aber
für die ermittler ergibt sie keinen sinn
hier steht stahl der güteklasse die
das heißt er sollte nicht brechen
wie bei vielen massengutfrachtern
bestehen deck und obere rumpf der flair
ausbruch festem stahl dieser ist
flexibel und absorbiert selbst heftigen
wellenschlag bei rauer see
der rumpf des schiffes hätte eigentlich
beweglicher sein und mehr aushalten
müssen
wenn ich zum beispiel lakritze lang
ziehe und verbiege verformt sie sich
bevor sie bricht
was hier geschehen ist ist unüblich und
schwer zu verstehen
gibt keinen sinn die ermittler stehen
vor einem rätsel
erhalten wie kann ein schiff das genau
für solche situationen konzipiert ist so
dramatisch versagen
die ermittler konzentrieren sich auf die
flexible stahlkonstruktion des schiffes
sie hatte dem sturm eigentlich stand
halten müssen
wie kann ein so flexibles material
spröde werden wie kann das sein da muss
mehr dahinterstecken
die ermittler nehmen die historie der
flair genauer unter die lupe
die flair wurde
1972 gebaut zum zeitpunkt des unglücks
war sie also 26 jahre alt damit wurde
ihre normale lebensdauer um acht jahre
überschritten
ziemlich alt für einen massengutfrachter
ermittler kein potter ist
sicherheitsexperte für schifffahrt
fragen
massengutfrachter werden sehr stark
beansprucht
einige der beförderten materialien
setzen ihnen schwer zu reisen erst zum
beispiel kommt in form von heißen
pellets an bord beim entladen können
auch die greifer das schiff beschädigen
schwere ladungen üben enorme kräfte auf
den rumpf aus manchmal überschreitet ein
schiff seine grenzen die flair hat viele
schwere einsätze hinter sich
er stellt sich heraus dass das schicksal
der flair kein einzelfall ist in den
sieben jahren vor dem unfall sind nicht
weniger als 99 massengutfrachter
gesunken
650 menschen kamen dabei ums leben
das waren alles frachter
unfassbar die zahlen sind schockierend
im schnitt ist jeden monat ein frachter
gesunken
manchmal ging es so schnell dass nicht
mal sos gefunkt wurde
die ermittler gehen einem beunruhigenden
verdacht nach könnten all diese
gesunkenen frachtschiffe auch in der
mitte durchgebrochen sein
niemand weiß was mit diesen schiffen
passiert ist die crew sind tot einfach
verschwunden
sollte sich der verdacht erhärten
während viele andere frachter in akuter
gefahr
die suche für die ermittler in den hafen
von rotterdam dem letzten hafen der
flair bevor sie sich auf den weg nach
kanada machte
wir wollten den lotsen sprechender das
schiff aus dem hafen von rotterdam
geführt hatte
danke dass sie sich zeit nehmen kann wie
kann ich helfen
ein lotse muss ein schiff sicher aus dem
hafen bringen er könnte uns wichtige
informationen liefern
der lotse navigiert jedes jahr tausende
von schiffen aus dem hafen dennoch kann
er sich an die fleher erinnern
die flyer ja ich weiß sie war leer und
hatte vorne einen geringeren tiefgang
das bedeutet dass der bug des schiffes
höher aus dem wasser ragt als das heck
bei ruhiger see ist das kein problem
bei sturm jedoch kann das gefährlich
werden
ja man muss sich das schiff wie eine
wippe vorstellen in diesem fall eine 180
meter lange wippe der bug kippt nach
vorn und rauscht dann krachend ins
wellental
für das material ein härtetest
diese beständigen schläge durch die
wellen führen dazu dass sich das
material mal hierhin mal dorthin liegt
ähnlich wie bei einer büroklammer die
man hin und her biegt kommt es
irgendwann zur ermüdung und schließlich
zum bruch die ermittler fragen sich ob
der bub bei schwerem seegang zu hoch
auch fragte
sie verlangsamen auf 5 kloten
haben die fortgesetzten schläge zum
auseinanderbrechen der flair gefühlt um
die belastung des rumpfes bei hohen
bällen zu verringern wird normalerweise
meerwasser in die ballasttanks des
schiffes gepumpt so liegt das schiff
tiefer im wasser und kommt besser durch
die wellen
halten
die ermittler wissen dass die flair den
hafen ohne ladung verlassen hat was sie
nicht wissen ist ob und wie viel ballast
der kapitän in die tanks füllen ließ
bevor das schiff in zwei teile zerbrach
wir wussten dass die flair leer war aber
nicht wie viel ballast sie an bord hatte
und an welchen stellen um das
herauszufinden müssen sie ihren ganzen
spürsinn aufbieten
sieh dir mal die form des eises an sie
analysieren fotos vom schiffsdeck
siehst du die quadratischen ränder
anhand der schnee und eis muster konnten
wir die verteilung des banners erkennen
denn ein mit wasser gefüllter tank
speichert die wärme länger als ein
leerer tank
mit salz wasser gefüllter tank speichert
genug wärme um den schnee an der
oberfläche zum schmelzen zu bringen
leere tanks sind kelter so dass sich
schnee und eis darüber ansammeln können
[Musik]
da ist nicht genug mehr wasser in den
tanks
wo schnee und eis liegen waren die tanks
höchstwahrscheinlich leer
mit lehrern ballasttanks in einen sturm
das ergibt keinen sinn
dann stoßen die ermittler auf eine
weitere interessante informationen
bei der letzten inspektion der flair
wurde festgestellt dass die meisten
ballasttanks verrostet und
reparaturbedürftig sind
der flyer wurden einige reparaturen in
den oberen seiten tanks durchgeführt
dafür musste das ballastwasser
abgelassen werden
sie durften unter auflagen weiter fahren
das heißt sie hatten ein vorgegebenes
zeitfenster in dem sie die reparaturen
durchführen mussten
dafür hatten sie nur wenige wochen zeit
sie standen unter druck
der kapitän wird sich gefragt haben was
muss gemacht werden ist es gefährlich
dass während der fahrt zu tun und
offenbar kam er zu dem schluss dass das
in ordnung ist
der lässt seine männer auf hoher see mit
den reparaturarbeiten beginnen doch er
hat die rechnung ohne den nordatlantik
gemacht
die wetterbedingungen mit hohem
wellengang und hurricane artigen winden
machten reparaturarbeiten während der
fahrt praktisch unmöglich
möglicherweise blieben einige
ballasttanks wegen der nicht
abgeschlossenen reparaturarbeiten leer
und das unbeladene schiff wurde zum
spielball der wellen
hat eine einzelne riesenwelle der schiff
auseinander gerissen
laut konstruktionsplänen müsste die
flair eigentlich selbst gegen schlimmste
brecher gewappnet sein
der rumpf war verstärkt um auch erz
transportieren zu können das schiff war
eigentlich robuster als vergleichbare
massengutfrachter
dennoch versagte es im unbeladenen
zustand
die ermittler sehen sich den aufbau des
schiffs genau an
vielleicht gab es ein problem dass auf
den bildern nicht zu erkennen war aber
das konnten wir nur herausfinden indem
wir das wrack selbst untersuchten
ermittler schon casting fährt mit der
irl einem schiff der kanadischen
küstenwache zum wrack der flair etwa 145
kilometer vor der küste von cape breton
er will das fragt mit einem
ferngesteuerten tauchboot untersuchen
das mit hochauflösenden kameras
ausgestattet ist
um wegen des wetters blieb uns nur ein
kleines zeitfenster das mussten wir
ausnutzen
das tauchboot gleitet in die tiefe für
die ermittler ist dies vielleicht die
letzte chance den rätselhaften fall
aufzuklären
das ist eine riskante operation der
roboter könnte sich da unten in kabeln
oder verbogenem metall verheddern
schlimmstenfalls verlieren wir einen
tauchroboter im wert von 100.000 dollar
ohne etwas erreicht haben
in 76 meter tiefe doch der bub der
fleher schließlich vor der linse auf
man gewöhnt sich nie an den anblick
eines so großen schiffes das plötzlich
aus der dunkelheit auftaucht
das lässt einen nicht kalt im grunde
genommen steht man am grab derer die es
nicht geschafft haben
[Musik]
der gesunkene buch ist kopfüber auf dem
meeresboden gelandet er stand auf dem
kopf und bewegte sich hin und her sodass
wir auch die unterseite seien okay dich
daran da hat die bruchstelle des rumpfes
sichtbar wird er kennt gar stellen etwas
seltsames an der bruchkante
[Musik]
zu unserer überraschung stießen wir auf
muschelschalen abdrücke sie sind
charakteristisch für ermüdungsfreies
die feinen risse weisen ein muster von
muschel abdrücken auf sie entstehen wenn
sich der stahl im lauf der zeit wieder
und wieder verbiegt
diese konzentrischen linien sind
eigentlich riss und ruhe linien das
material reist in etappen chris pause
riss pause riss pause so wachsen sie
immer weiter da könnte es angefangen
haben die ermüdung risse bilden sich im
stahl und sind daher unsichtbar für den
kapitän und die crew
da noch mehr
wir fanden immer mehr risse sie waren
klein aber in ihrer summe waren sie
tickende zeitbomben die
risse wuchsen immer weiter und verdanken
sich miteinander bis sie schließlich
eine kritische größe erreichen ähnlich
wie bei einem glas
ein feiner kratzer an der oberfläche
kann da einen stoß plötzlich zu einem
unvorhersehbaren bruch führen
im fall des schiffs waren es die an
prallenden wellen die den stahlbogen und
schließlich zu einem schnellen bruch und
damit zur katastrophe führten
der riss an bord der flair hatte sich um
den gesamten rumpf herum ausgebreitet
und zwar in sekundenbruchteilen
buchstäblich mit schallgeschwindigkeit
sechs monate nach dem untergang der
flair haben die ermittler die
unglücksursache gefunden korrosion
spuren an den ermüdung frison deuten
darauf hin dass die risse schon vor
jahren entstanden sind
vielleicht wuchsen die risse schon ein
oder zwei jahre lang und dann bedurfte
es nur noch eines auslöser für die
katastrophe
als die flair rotterdam verließ war
hatte niemand an bord dass ein unglück
nur eine frage der zeit sein würde sie
verlangsamen auf 5 knoten
die stürmische atlantik überfahrt
schwächte das schiff weiter und die
heftigen wellen der calwer straße gaben
ihm schließlich den rest
die inspektion des chefs verlief ohne
beanstandungen bei ultraschall tests an
rumpf der flair sind die tödlichen
ermüdung risse nicht entdeckt worden
das wirft die frage auf wer diese
inspektion durchgeführt hatte wie
gründlich sie war ob die untersuchungs
instrumente den vorgaben entsprachen
wir mussten eine sicherheitswarnung
herausgegeben denn überall auf der welt
könnten schiffe in gefahr sein
[Musik]
wir müssen diese schiffe waren die risse
sind tickende zeitbomben
versteckte ermüdungsbrüche wie auf der
flair könnten auch anderen frachtern zum
verhängnis werden die frage ist nur
können die ermittler sie warnen bevor es
zu spät ist
[Musik]
sie benachrichtigen flaggen staaten auf
der ganzen welt und weisen auf die
gefahr durch kaum sichtbare ermüdung
skizze bei massengutfrachtern hin
es gibt etliche schiffe ähnlicher bauart
haben sie auch risse dann könnten wir
ihnen sagen wie man sie entdeckt die
schifffahrtsbranche ist alarmiert 14
massengutfrachter werden sofort als
stark gefährdet eingestuft
von zwei schiffen ähnlicher bauart die
in kanadischen gewässern unterwegs waren
hatte eines risse wie die flair
wären sie nicht entdeckt worden hätte
dem schiff die gleiche katastrophe
gedroht
für mich persönlich aber auch für meine
kollegen war das definitiv eine wichtige
sache
aber die industrie muss nicht nur die
qualität der inspektionen verbessern
hat die besatzung in der unglücksnacht
schiff verließ trug einer der männer
einen überlebensanzug
spezielle neoprenanzüge verbessern
messbar die überlebenschancen auf
offenem meer
es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass sich
seeleute auf solche notfälle vorbereiten
ich war selbst schon in der situation
dass ich meinen rettungs anzug
vorsorglich aus dem schrank geholt hatte
auf kanadischen schiffen gehören
überlebens anzüge inzwischen zum
standard aber das ist nicht überall so
danke für das treffen
chefermittler bürger coni trifft die
besitzer der flair in griechenland ich
möchte mit ihnen über die flair reden
insbesondere über die zahl der rettungs
anzüge an bord
es waren sechs rettungs anzüge an bord
entsprechend der gesetzlichen vorgaben
25 männern was sollten sie machen klose
ich war schockiert als ich hörte dass
rettungs anzüge nicht für alle
besatzungsmitglieder vorgeschrieben
waren
wir brauchen bessere gesetze ich hoffe
dass sie uns dabei unterstützen
angesichts zigtausende schiffe die
tagtäglich in den weltmeeren unterwegs
sind drängen die ermittler auf eine neue
gesetzgebung damit nicht noch mehr
seeleute sterben sie hören von mir
sie stützen sich dabei auf studien des
kanadischen militärs im hinblick auf die
überlebenschancen in kalten gewässern
wir benutzen ein computermodell um
verschiedene szenarien zu simulieren
wir können daten über luft- und
wassertemperatur und die art der
getragenen kleidung eingeben gibt es
rettungswesten hätte ein überlebensanzug
die personen gerettet
in dem modell werden die erfolgs
prognosen mit und ohne rettungs anzug
verglichen
personen mit leichter kleidung hätten
etwa zwei bis zweieinhalb stunden
überlebt mit rettungs anzügen stieg die
überlebenszeit auf 12 bis 14 stunden
das ergebnis ist wenig überraschend mit
überlebens anzügen wären heute deutlich
mehr crewmitglieder der flair noch am
leben
man hofft immer etwas bewirken zu können
aber natürlich geht es auch um die
familien sie brauchen antworten was ist
da passiert und warum
die untersuchungsergebnisse und die
auswertung der studien werden der
internationalen
seeschifffahrtsorganisation imo
vorgelegt
die imo und ihre 150 mitgliedsstaaten
stimmten uns zu seitdem ist pro
besatzungsmitglied ein rettungs anzug
vorgeschrieben
[Musik]
leider bedarf es oft erst eines
tragischen ereignisses mit todesopfern
um einen wandel herbeizuführen
die flair war eines dieser tragischen
ereignisse
[Musik]
21 jahre nach der tragödie treffen apa
und forellen sich wieder
die beiden männer werden das tragische
unglück nie vergessen
früher war es mein traum mit 35 chef
ingenieur zu werden jetzt nicht mehr
ich bin nie wieder an bord eines
schiffes gegangen
die männer konnten zu ihren familien
zurückkehren den meisten ihrer kollegen
war das nicht vergönnt
das wäre vermeidbar gewesen
ich hoffe dass die schifffahrtsbranche
ihre lektion aus dem unglück der flair
gelernt hat